[Music]
brian joins us in oklahoma city brian
welcome to the show
thanks guys uh so i just had a few
questions for you guys
all right
we have a few answers let's do it yes i
well i hope so so currently me and my
household um
at single income it's about 56 000 a
year
um
so before we got on on to financial
peace university and everything else i
actually didn't even know that y'all
show until i got the new vehicle
and um
that was about 20 000 into debt
and
so after watching um the first couple of
episodes on the financial peace
university
we thought it was more lucrative for us
to
change the baby steps for us from one to
two and do it backwards
pay off our debt first and then
save because our budget's real tight and
we wouldn't have been able to save the
thousand dollars
completely up for like
four or five months and i felt like that
was way too long for us to try to
save up a thousand dollars versus
keeping credit cards and not paying more
on our car that we could have paid over
that time what what do you guys think
about that
well brian uh my brain hurts because you
just said the word lucrative while also
saying you have zero dollars in the bank
while you pay off debt how was this a
money-making scheme to you
so well i don't miss i don't necessarily
think it's a money-making scheme i think
it's more along the lines of
um it's going to help us
pay off debt faster and then we can save
afterwards what happens if you get a
flat tire
well i i have a side job that i make
about 500 bucks a weekend on that's your
emergency fund dude that's it
500 bucks a week so you can two weeks
you'll have a thousand bucks
right well and that's that's kind of
what what i had always thought um but
that was aside from our regular
household income because the other thing
is djing weddings and so it doesn't
necessarily always happen but all of
your all of your income all of your
income all of it side hustles um front
hustles back hustles top hustles bottom
hustle all the hustles
all that jumps into is your household
income so if you have a household income
of 56 000 and you make an extra 500
bucks a week you're gonna toss that on
top of that and all that together is is
piled in there okay
okay brian i don't know
i'm listening to the story i don't see
this as an exception to the rule i don't
see you as unique or special here you
save up a thousand dollars then we
attack the debt using the debt snowball
from smallest to largest ignoring the
interest rate and uh i might look at
selling this car what's it worth
uh i have no idea what it's like we just
bought it i think in uh
in may
um before i even found out about call
and see what you can get for it if you
can get uh if you can get uh even steven
for it then
go sell it and then buy something half
the price you have another car
uh yeah it's a it's a beer car and i
mean it's paid off um but i i put a lot
of miles on it uh going back and forth
to weddings and i drive it back to work
the other car is
like our sacred car we don't really take
it anywhere if we don't have to there it
is the sacramento there's no such thing
as a sacred coat it's a depreciating
asset it's a piece of metal that's going
down in value every day there's nothing
sacred about it yes and um don't keep a
car payment in a nice car for a side
hustle
i had to and my wife get out of debt i
don't tell the story a lot because it
makes me sad and it makes me want to cry
george i had to sell a couple of my
guitars
and so it may be that you look at your
nice dj table and say hey i haven't been
djing i'm gonna sell my gear and get a
thousand dollar emergency fund sell
everything until you get that thousand
bucks how much total that figure it out
oh uh we only have about
23 000 in debt including the car what's
the other you said 20 on the car what's
the other three
uh they're like just some small credit
cards okay so listen dude if you sold
the car
and then you worked uh six weeks on your
side hustle you're debt free you're done
you're free
right before the car before we got the
car we were only a couple thousand
dollars in the debt but we we didn't
really have a good car
for us to use and it was more of a
headache to try to find a good used one
so and it was real hard for us to get
financing because we have that credit
and before david ramsey before we found
out about financial peace university
we really didn't know you know the
principles of
well
now you know brian ignorance was bliss
until now
now you know
can we just say this you you've had
tough you've got tough credit you've had
a bad experiences with money i haven't
been wise with it
let me just ask you this point blank
have your ways worked
as in finances yes are you happy with
where you are financially
do you feel like you're crushing it
i feel like i could do better i don't
think i'm crushing it but i know that
i'm not doing it that's all we're here
to do is help you do better that's what
i hope you do better man in this this
program millions of people have done it
we the baby steps are in the order they
are because they've been tried and trued
over millions of people and you're no
exception and if you go all in on this
i'm telling scorched earth we're doing
the baby steps exactly as is we're not
special we're going to be one of those
tens of millions of people who changes
our family tree sells the car sell some
gear do whatever it takes
man it will change your financial
situation and even better it's going to
change you it's going to change how you
make decisions stop singing yeah but
yeah just go do it go do it